ovo she's Drake's you know rapper Draya  yeah he's a clothing line you know Drake  says he's a fan of ozark he is a big fan  of Mozart maybe he'll send me some  clothes maybe he will result it's not  playing this game show  lying running it's both tired wrapping  up your ozark more cooing expected to  hit I think September I think that's the  goal he's drinking in any episodes no  I'd like to get him and his sweet wet  shirts in while we wait on that Drake  cameo Jason is teaming up with another  Canadian Rachel McAdams in game right  guys make sure you get a piece of cheese  okay Roger dad you drive safe Jennifer  Aniston has played your wife five times  at this point you have to call her and  be like I think we're gonna go another  way this time when I told her about  Rachel McAdams she's she I'm not trying  to answer this you don't have to you  don't have to hear the headline rachel  is uh is fantastic and and was so easy  to get along with and she's just so good